>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ATTORNEY
MICHAEL COHEN HAS FILED A
DEFAMATION SUIT AGAINST BUZZ
FEED THE BLOG FOR PUBLISHING
A DOSSIER OF UNVERIFIED
>> CO-' TOLD GOMEZ AT FOX I
LIE-FILLED DOSSIER.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THOSE DETAILS.
SPEAKING OF THE DOSSIER,
FUSION GPS CO-FOUNDER GLEMP
UNTIL NOW HIS REMARKS HAD
REMAINED SECRET.
TODAY DIANNE FEINSTEIN, THE
DEMOCRAT OF CALIFORNIA,
ABRUPTLY RELEASED A
TRANSCRIPT OF SIMPSON'
REMARKS.
IT RAISES NEW QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
DURING HIS TESTIMONY SIMPSON
SAID THE FBI FOUND THE
DOSSIER BELIEVABLE BECAUSE
IT HAD A SOURCE INSIDE THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN WHO PROVIDED
SOMEBODY OR HIS LAWYER SAID
SOMEBODY HAD BEEN MURDERED
DUE TO THE RELEASE OF THE
DOSSIER.
CALIFORNIA AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> I SIT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TONIGHT AND I HOPE MY
PARENTS TAKE CARE OF YOU.
>> Tucker: HAVING DINNER
WITH THEM AFTER THE SHOW.
>> GOOD.
>> Tucker: SPEAKING OF I
WANT TO GIVE CREDIT WHERE
IT'S DUE GOOD FOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN FOR RELEASING.
THIS I THINK THE PUBLIC HAS
A RIGHT TO KNOW AND I'M GLAD
SHE DID.
THERE ARE A LOT OF
LOT OF BOMBSHELLS BUT THERE
IS ONE POINT THAT REALLY
STICKS OUT.
HIRED ON BEHALF OF THE
HILLARY CAMPAIGN, SPOKE TO
THE FBI, WHICH TOLD HIM THAT
THEY HAD A SOURCE WITHIN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND THAT THAT
SOURCE CORROBORATED THERE
WAS A RELATION BETWEEN
RUSSIA AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
SO HERE YOU HAVE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, SEPTEMBER 2016,
THE OBAMA FBI GIVING DIRT ON
I KNOW YOU ARE A PARTISAN
DEMOCRAT.
DOLLS THAT BOTHER YOU AT
ALL?
>> WELL, NO.
FBI.
THESE ARE CAREER AGENTS WHO
ADMINISTRATION.
>> NOT CONTROLLED.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THAT THE OBAMA FBI TELLS
HILLARY CLINTON'S OPPOSITION
RESEARCHER IN THE MIDDLE OF
A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IN
WHICH SHE IS RUNNING THAT
IN AMERICA?
>> FIRST OFF, I WILL TELL
YOU, TUCKER, LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOLKS ARE QUITE OFFENDED BY
THESE ATTACKS CALLING IT,
YOU KNOW, THE OBAMA FBI.
POLITICS.
>> Tucker: THEY MAY NOT.
SOME OF THEM DO WE KNOW FROM
STRZOK'S TEXTS TO HIS
GIRLFRIEND SOME CARE
POLITICS AND OPENLY
PARTISAN.
WE HAVE IN THE RELEASE OF
THIS TRANSCRIPT EVIDENCE AND
I THINK WE BOTH AGREE IT'S
REAL THAT THE FBI TOLD
HILLARY CLINTON'S OPPOSITION
RESEARCHER SOMETHING
NEGATIVE ABOUT HER OPPONENT.
THAT IS NOT SUPPOSED TO
HAPPEN, IS IT?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE FBI
USUALLY KEEPS INFORMATION ON
CLOSE HOLD.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WAS A, I
INVESTIGATOR FOR FUSION GPS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS
FBI.
I THINK WE SHOULD KNOW,
TUCKER.
THOSE ARE FAIR QUESTIONS.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND.
STEELE WAS WORKING FOR
FUSION -- I MEAN, CORRECT ME
IF I AM MISSTATING.
DETAINER TO THE HILLARY
CAMPAIGN TO DIG UP DIRT ON
DONALD TRUMP.
I GET IT HE IS IN EFFECT
WORKING AS AN OPO RESEARCHER
FOR HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN AND THE FBI IS
REVEALING SOURCES AND
METHODS TO HIM IN THE MIDDLE
OF A PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
>> I THINK WE STOP THE
WITH RUSSIA.
THAT, TO ME, IS MORE
CONCERNING.
>> Tucker: MAYBE.
I MEAN I'M SURE -- I DON'T
KNOW, THE GUY HAS BEEN IN
BUSINESS A LONG TIME.
I MEAN, LOOK, I HAVE NO
IDEA.
ABOUT HIS FINANCIAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH VARIOUS
RUSSIANS.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW, I'M
AGNOSTIC ON IT.
>> THE DOSSIER HAS BEEN
PROVED TRUE.
>> Tucker: I'M JUST SAYING I
KNOW WHEN WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
WHEN POLITICS
SUBINVESTIGATORS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AND THAT STARTS TO
FEDERAL AUTHORITY LIKE THE
CAMPAIGNS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PRESIDENTIAL YEAR.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY OVER THE
HE COULD HAVE KEPT THEM AND
THROW THEM OFF THE
INVESTIGATION.
HE THREW THEM OFF.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELSE YOU
WOULD WANT HIM TO DO.
HE IS GONE.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T KNOW
THAT ACTUALLY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE ENTIRELY
POSSIBLE THAT THE FBI PAID
MONEY TO FUSION GPS.
WE DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT, DO WE?
THAT'S AN OPEN QUESTION.
IT'S BEEN ALLEGED AND THEY
HAVEN'T REALLY ANSWERED THE
QUESTION.
AREN'T YOU ANXIOUS TO KNOW?
>> LET'S ASK IT BUT ALSO ASK
THE QUESTIONS AROUND WHAT'S
ALLEGED IN THE DOSSIER.
WHOLE MOUNTAIN OF EVIDENCE
THAT HAS BEEN ACCUMULATED
SO ALL OF THE ARROWS
CONTINUE TO POINT TO A
PERSONAL POLITICAL AND
FINANCIAL RELATIONSHIP THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD WITH THE
RUSSIANS AND WHETHER IT
AMOUNTED TO A CRIME OR NOT
IS BOB MUELLER'S JOB.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO ALL WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN IN THE
NEXT ELECTION.
>> Tucker: I HOPE WE CAN